alors ce vendredi l'ukraine a confirmé
que les forces russes ont pris le
contrôle de liman c'est une ville
d'environ 20000 habitants à l'ouest de
severodonezk un peu plus vers le nord
dans la région de donetsk est une ville
vraiment stratégiques mais qui a été
triste substance tellement détruite par
les forces de frappe et les
bombardements russes avant que les
russes prennent le contrôle mais cette
une deuxième ville de taille moyenne
dans la région dont les ukrainiens ont
perdu le contrôle ces derniers jours il
ya eu déjà suite lothar sq qui est au
sud de severodonetsk et severodonetsk
eux-mêmes qui est vraiment la cible
principale des russes en ce moment la
ville la plus à l'est encore contrôlée
par l'ukraine pour le moment les
autorités ukrainiennes affirme que cette
ville est encore sous leur contrôle il y
aurait eu des combats aux abords de la
ville sur le sol mais les ukrainiens
affirment avoir repoussé une offensive
sur le sol pour rentrer dans la ville
mais ils disent que ces verrous donetsk
est à deux tiers en cercle et par les
russes mais l'accès à la ville depuis
l'ukraine est encore possible mais c'est
bien sûr par des routes qui sont assez
souvent bombardé donc il est très
dangereux d'accéder à ses bureaux
donetsk et sa ville soeur les sites
chose qui est juste l'autre côté de la
rivière syversen qui donetsk à rivière
sur laquelle les russes ont détruit un
pont mais il est à deux autres ponts qui
sont au corps passable même si assez
souvent aussi ciblé par l'artillerie
alors c'est une situation vraiment très
très très difficile à severodonetsk la
région de lougansk donc à 95% maintenant
contrôlée par les forces russes et
sergei die le gouverneur ukrainien de la
région de luhansk il dit que 60 % des
immeubles à ses bureaux d'onet que vont
devoir être complètement reconstruits
ils sont si gravement endommagé qu'ils
ne sont pas réparables une situation
extrêmement compliquée périlleuse que
vous venez de décrire l'univers depuis
kiev là où vous vous trouvez de nombreux
responsables ukrainiens ont donc fait
l'aveu de cette situation et réclame
davantage d'armes de munitions
oui absolument les dirigeants ukrainiens
enchères réclame plus d'armes de
l'occident le ministre des affaires
étrangères admis trop coulé bas a dit
nous avons besoin d'armes d'armes et
d'armes et plus précisément des systèmes
de lance roquettes multiples de l'avis
de plusieurs experts ukrainiens et des
autorités ce serait vraiment ce genre de
système qui pourrait changer la donne le
royaume uni a déjà appuyé l'idée de
renvoyer ce genre de système à l'ukraine
mais bien sûr tout envoi d'armes à
l'ukraine prend du temps avant que ça
peut arriver sur le front dans le
donbass on sait que une partie des
leaders envoyés par les etats-unis sont
arrivés dans une basse on ne sait même
pas ainsi tous ses 98 eur que les états
unis ont envoyé juste à titre d'exemple
sont déjà en position est une activité
du l'hiver